clay is with us in Columbia South
Carolina hi clay welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show thank you Dave and I want to
thank you and your team for everything
you've done you really have me energized
debate about being intentional with my
finances I'm pumped I'm reading all the
books and really into it my wife and I
have very different spending and saving
behaviors and I'm trying to get her on
board and take FPU with me which has
been a bit of a struggle one concern I
have how does she not want to go to FPU
well I think I think it's the budgeting
part but one concern I have about the
Ovilus system is the safety risk for
carrying around a bunch of cash so my
question is how do you feel about using
low fever loadable debit cards as a
replacement for the cash and the
envelopes why would you do that did you
know that there are no crooks who have
x-ray vision and then can look into your
purse and see that you don't have 14
maxed out credit cards instead you have
a handful of cash nobody knows that my
wife has been carrying cash for 30 years
in an envelope system I've been carrying
cash for 45 years in my front pocket and
I've never been robbed ever and I've
never lost the money ever okay you know
I was just thinking about some of the
solder surfing here and see unless you
have you know cash anomalies and making
a quick grab yeah it can be done you
have to use common sense but you'll do
that for your credit cards too they'll
do that a purse thief is going to be a
purse thief you know that's not gonna
the cash does not increase that and
you're not carrying around $10,000 I
mean you carry around 500 bucks to go
the grocery store or something well it
was in the food envelope it's not like
it's gonna break you or make you you got
bigger problems than cash versus prepaid
because you're missing one of the main
data points of people who build wealth
and that's been on the same page with
your spouse yeah I mean the rest of this
stuff is minor details I don't find
anybody that didn't become a mill
because they carried cash envelopes and
I don't find anybody that didn't become
a millionaire because they chose to do
prepaid debit instead of cash envelopes
I do find lots of people that don't
become millionaires because they're know
the same page with their spouse so
you're asking the wrong questions on the
wrong issues you're dealing with little
bitty tiny things that don't really
matter well you need to get the big
things solved and here's the thing on
the budget here's what rachel says about
a budget and you can tell your wife this
a budget is not constraining unless you
want it to be because you're like
grown-ups I'm not coming to your house
and gonna do your budget for you and
make you live on it
you're going to do your budget so all a
budget is is a spending plan
it's permission to spend on some
categories without guilt and without
being a child so the only limitations
you have by doing a budget are the ones
you put on yourself
lots of people choose to put limitations
on themselves so that they can win they
live like no one else so that later they
can live and give like no one else but
I'm not coming to your house you're the
ones gonna put the limitations on you if
you do it all it's up to you and up to
her she gets to decide she's got a vote